[Music]
whether you like the president or not
what separates him from every other
president is that he's not one to hold
his finger to the political winds before
he makes a decision he tries to make
decisions that are right decision that
are best for you and me they're not
always popular and of course the most
difficult ones will always be questioned
yesterday's decision was one of them the
deal was to reopen the government
through February 15th creating a
bipartisan bicameral committee tasks
with negotiating an agreement on border
security the president made clear though
he's sticking to building a barrier we
really have no choice but to build a
powerful wall or steel barrier if we
don't get a fair deal from Congress the
government will either shut down on
February 15th again or I will use the
powers afforded to me under the laws and
the Constitution of the United States to
address this emergency the attacks were
immediate full-bore and relentless
instead of giving the president credit
for recognizing the damage to this
country he was attacked by virtually
everyone instead of people saying thank
goodness someone in Washington
recognizes the need to compromise
someone who actually understands the
purpose of government is to serve the
people he sees people who live paycheck
to paycheck having a difficult time
buying groceries and paying their bills
airports closed preventing people from
business trips visiting family members
as well as the attendant economic
hardships and unlike the obstructionist
and the Trump haters who don't give a
damn about ordinary Americans he simply
couldn't let it go on he
not cave he made a tactical decision a
strategy decision to pick the ground to
fight on he chose to stop the fight
today to fight another day
and that day will be February 15th
but of course Chuck crowed hopefully now
the president has learned his lesson no
one should ever underestimate the
speaker as Donald Trump has learned
Chuck I hate it to break it to you this
isn't a game
it's not about under estimating people
it's about people without a paycheck
something that you're not willing to go
without and Nancy got off her broom long
enough to say our unity is our power and
that is what maybe the president
underestimated and Ann Coulter blasted
Trump for not keeping his promise for
the border wall saying he lied we
thought that he wouldn't care what the
elites thought and he'd actually keep
his promises on this and he still
doesn't care what the elites think he
cared about the people who unlike you
don't have enough money to take care of
their families he couldn't tolerate
airports shut down and you want to
compare him to Reagan when Reagan fired
the striking air traffic controllers
here's the difference an a president
does not have the right to fire
non-essential employees during a
government shutdown OPM regulations
under 5 CFR part 75 - Reagan firing the
air traffic controllers in 1981 because
they were in violation of the law that
situation and is totally different and
not analogous public safety workers have
no right to strike it was the same
approach Calvin Coolidge took when the
Boston police went on strike these
people they don't understand Donald
Trump they just want to criticize him
like they did with other non popular
decisions like meeting with Kim Jong
who hasn't by the way launched a
ballistic missile since the meeting like
the tariffs which were unpopular but
seem now to be working folks the war
isn't over yet remember Donald Trump is
a man willing to take the shots to
change the norm in order to do what he
thinks is best for the country very
often he's dead on closing the
government torrid him opening it whether
it's a popular move is irrelevant
in his mind and remember this war is not
over it's nothing but a hollow victory
for the Democrats On February 15 that
the committee does not come back with a
workable solution which would be a shock
to me because Congress is certainly not
about getting the job done they kicked
the can down the road with the approval
of presidents like Obama and Clinton and
Bush with no one looking to actually get
something done this president could do
the same thing I believe he will not
because another continuing resolution is
not his style
I believe the president will call for
emergency funding for the wall he's
tried everything else the only thing I
would ask is that he makes sure it
doesn't get to the ninth circuit aka the
ninth circus the idea of Congress going
on yet another vacation the day after
February 15th with all of this unsettled
without any kind of resolution is a just
another reminder to the American people
of what Congress cares about themselves
their vacations and the lobbyists who
fund those vacations but I'm here to
tell you never underestimate this
president this president lives to fight
another day
and that's why open